first prep the veg chopped spring onions  shallots a clove of garlic and chilli to  taste then thinly sliced celery add a  bay leaf and thyme bed ready  and oil to a pan and fry  season then add mussels and stir  mussels were my favourite shellfish  cheap healthy and delicious  cover and sting for a couple of minutes  as the muscles open Advil move an  aromatic fortified wine  and 150 mil of dry white wine on a high  heat reduce the liquid to create a  source discard any muscles that are  still shut  then finish with creme fraiche and chop  parsley  the  minimal prep and cooked in less than 10  minutes my mussels with celery and chili  impressive affordable and super speedy  sliced spring onions chopped spring  greens and trimmer head of broccoli is  it really nice sort of sweet earthy  creamy flavor it's incredible